as commanded about 10 search warrants in  Brussels TV and Halle Villefort at the  request of the federal prosecution  office this search worth warrants were  executed in an investigation concerned  several people who we think are an  operational sell a certain of certain  people came back from Syria and October  attorneys during the investigation we  found that this group was about to  commit terrorist attacks in Belgium  during the search warrants in VA certain  suspects immediately opened fire with  automatic weapons at Special Forces of  the police they opened fire during  several minutes before being neutralized  two of the suspects were killed atherton  has been arrested luckily during this  intervention no policeman was Hans  neither a civilian the investigation is  still going on and you will understand  that we cannot give any further  information another press conference  will be organized tomorrow at eleven  o'clock here at the federal prosecution  office